hey guys tony and peter here we just
played the nintendo switch yeah we got a
lot of hands-on time we have like a
five-hour events it was a pretty long
one one of the things we played it's a
little bit of a minigame collection it's
called 12 switch yeah this is a game
they showed off last night it's one of
the two games that's launching with the
system whoa actually one of the two big
games let's say and it kind of reminded
me of something like wii sports right
but it was a little bit more it was
different it had this meta element to it
where you have to scare people in the
eyes so basically what you know it's a
collection of games where you use these
the two joypad joy colin controllers and
you perform various actions and like one
of the games we played I was gunslinger
which they show your presentation where
you literally end up staring someone in
the eye and you wait for this audio cue
and it's you know it's a shoot a QA for
that person to pull and shoot and timing
is important but y'all set make sure
your aim is true yes so you can end up
just shooting into the dirt as opposed
to shoot in your actual opponent and and
the interesting thing when you're
staring that opponent down as you said
is that the TV which is normally the
focus when you're playing a game is
completely irrelevant yeah all you're
doing is standing there staring down
your opponent right and and waiting for
that cue of like ready aim fire yeah I
don't know how many people out there
like to stare in the eyes of other folks
for extended periods of time but it's an
icebreaker sorts yeah it certainly
follows into that hey break it out at a
party with a couple people see what
happens kind of vibe yeah was that your
favorite of the bunch it's hard to say I
also like the samurai game which
essentially one person is supposed to
swing a sword the other person has to
catch it and so the timing is all up to
the person with the sword yeah you know
you faked me out a couple times and I'd
kill me because I couldn't catch it that
one's pretty good there was also ball
count it's so you sort of remember you
hold the controller in one hand and you
tilt it and using the HD rumble feature
inside you can feel sort of like these
balls moving around but you don't know
how many are in there that's the point
of the game you have to guess so kind of
like price is right whoever gets closest
to the actual number is declared the
winner right and that's things they
talked about the HD Rumble as like one
of the big features of these new joy
cons and it really is amazing when you
were sitting there rolling it around on
your hands you
you feel distinct rumbles or distinct
falls in there yeah it's it's not like
it feels like real right but it's
different than normal Rumble so it's at
least some sort of advancement I think
the lat we played two more played table
tennis game which was a bit hard because
that's all about you're literally
playing tennis with no visual cues it's
all audio cues so you have to guess when
the ball was bouncing I found that one a
bit difficult to grasp yeah it was a bit
strange in the timing sometimes and on
top of that you know there's the
standard volley that you can do but you
can also lob you can also go for like a
power shots and when you do that the
timing changes yeah so it's audio cues
to begin with but then when you start
messing with the timing of those audio
cues it can be it can be tricky to keep
up yeah but by far the weirdest
experiment we played was milk where you
essentially you hold the joy cons you
know vertically and there are two
buttons and you have to move your hand
up and down and press the buttons like
in sequence as though you're milking a
cow and that is literally like a point
of the game is to see who can fill in
those glasses with milk a little bit
disturbing but unusual in a way that's
fun right like I can't think of any
other game like that all right well
Peter thank you very much for joining me
for plenty more switch coverage we've
got interviews we've got gameplay clips
head on over to gamespot
[Music]